[inaudible].
Welcome to native link.com course
on using the IPA to help you with
pronunciation in a foreign language
or any language you're learning.
When we talk about vowels in
the context of IPA or phonetics,
we don't tend to say things like the
letter a or the letter u or the vowel you
even instead we break down valves by
their features and features are kind of
like the component parts of vows.
Each val has multiple features.
The first of these features is val height.
If you want to think
about it anatomically,
you can distinguish different val heights
by considering the position of your
job when you make a certain
vowels. So for instance,
when I make the open sound or my jaw is
in a different position than it is when
I say the clothes val e,
so my jaw opens up between e and. O.
You can also relate height two how
close your tongue is to the roof of your
mouth. It's closer when you say the
sound e than it is when you say,
aw,
we can distinguish open
mid and close vowels.
Backness is the other feature we
should distinguish at this point.
Backness involves instead,
what we can think of as how far forward
and how far back our tongue is in our
mouth. That's the anatomical
way of thinking about it.
So if you again, say the vowel e,
your tongue is fairly far forward
in your mouth, but if you say all,
you pull it back. So that's the feature.
Backness we can distinguish
three levels of backness.
The first one is going to be
back. The second one is central,
and the third is front.
Using those two features,
backness and height,
we can lay vowels out on the table with
the x axis being backness and the y axis
being height.
This will allow you to lay out all of
your basic values on a chart and to be
able to pronounce them in
relation to each other.
Let's take a look at one of those charts,
and I'll pronounce the sounds for you.
E Eh, Eh, Eh, ah,
ah, ah, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh
[inaudible].